j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public débat volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour avec cette question
à quoi sert l'ONU bientôt 2 années de
guerre en Ukraine plus de 100 jours de
terreur au Proche Orient euh ont redonné
de la vigueur aux critiques du machin
dénoncé par le général de Gaulle en son
temps et en ses termes avant d'en
débattre on rappelle
euh pour l'organisation comment pourquoi
elle a été créée après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale Flora sauvage l'ONU un colosse
au pied d'argile entre ingérance et
impuissance l'Organisation des Nations
Unies est la cible de critique créé au
lendemain de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
pour maintenir la paix elle compte 193
états 15 membres siègent au Conseil de
sécurité dont C permanents les
États-Unis la Russie le Royaume-Uni la
Chine et la France il dispose chacun
d'un droit de vetto qui bloque parfois
la prise de décision à l'image de la
proposition de résolution appelant à un
cesser le feu immédiat à Gaza qui s'est
opposé au véteau des États-Unis is une
fois de plus ce conseil a échoué par
désunion et par refus de s'engager
véritablement dans une négociation un
droit de vetau qui paralyse le
fonctionnement de l'organisation des
nations- Unies et la Russie aussi a
beaucoup utilisé ce droit de vetto elle
l'a utilisé plus de 150 fois et quand un
des membres permanents met son droit de
véto il bloque une décision qui a été
votée par la majorité des 193
États-membres de l'ONU donc ce n'est pas
des oc courcircuité par d'autres grands
forums internationaux l'ONU est affaibli
comme le reconnaît son secrétaire
général le Conseil de sécurité principal
forum de résolution pacifique des
différents internationaux est paralysé
par des divisions
géostratégique cet état de fait
compromet les solutions de l'Ukraine au
Moyen-Orient en passant par la
Birmanie certains pays du Sud récl une
refonte de son fonctionnement depuis 30
ans il y a des tentatives de réforme de
tout d'abord élargir le Conseil de
sécurité en ajoutant des nouveaux États
permanents comme un pays d'Afrique ça se
justifierait parce que l'Afrique va
bientôt compter 2 milliards d'habitants
et n'a toujours pas de membres
permanents au Conseil de sécurité ou
encore suspendre ou voir annuler
interdire le veto puisque le veto
paralyse l'ONU à l'heure des multiples
crises climatiques militairees et
économiqu l'ONU semble à bout de souffle
créé il y a 68 ans il est plus que
jamais nécessaire de réformer cette
organisation
à quoi sert l'ONU comment l'a réformer
on en débat avec pierasky bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
chroniqueur France interre et et lob
spécialiste des questions de
géopolitique et puis vous publiez
apparaître la semaine prochaine une
terre doublement promise Israël
Palestine un siècle de conflit c'est aux
éditions Stock Alexandra Novoselov
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes chercheur
associé au Centre euh tuusdii de
l'Université Paris Panthéon Assas et
vous publiez le Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies aux éditions du CNRS
Johann soufi bonsoir et bienvenue vous
êtes avocat procureur spécialisé dans le
domaine de la justice pénale
international et les droits de l'homme
et puis vous avez été chef du bureau des
affaires juridiques de l'agence de l'inu
pour les réfugiés palestiniens à Gaza et
tamtranui et rester à mes côtés
évidemment éditorialiste politique je
vais rappeler tiens pour commencer les
premiers mots de l'article 1 de la
Charte de l'ONU définie le 26 juin
1945 maintenir la paix et la sécurité
internationale et à cette fin prendre
des mesures collectives efficaces en vue
de prévenir et d'écarter les menaces à
la paix et de réprimer tout acte
d'agression ou autre rupture de la paix
pierreasky est-ce qu'on peut dire que
c'était une mission impossible se sont
donnés les rédacteurs de la Charte euh
alors il faut se souvenir de de l'époque
on sortait de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et on sortait de l'échec de la Société
des nations qui est l'ancêtre de l'ONU
qui n'avait pas réussi à à empêcher la
la montée des des périls on se souvient
de enfin on se souvient de la la
présence d' ccier qui vient dénoncer
l'invasion italienne à Genève à la SDN
et qui dit cette phrase incroyable il
dit si vous n'arrêtez pas cette guerre
en Éthiopie aujourd'hui vous serez les
prochains et et effectivement on l'a pas
écouté il y a eu ensuite l'Espagne il y
a eu la Seconde Guerre mondiale donc on
a compé on a on a tiré les leçons de cet
échec et on a créé une organisation
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale qui
était censé répondre aux faiblesses de
la de la précédente ave avec tout un
arsenal qui était les sanctions par
exemple les les casques bleus donc les
forces de maintien de la paix tout un un
tas d'organisations aussi filiales pour
s'occuper aussi des questions de
développement de et cetera d'aide
humanitaire ce qui je pense pas que ce
soit le le à l'époque je pense qu'on
pensait que ça répondait à à à aux
besoin ce que ce qu'onait pas anticipé
moi j'avais intervieé un des fondateurs
de l'ONU qui me disait ça a très bien
marché pendant 6 mois parce que la
guerre froide est arrivée et la guerre
froide a grippé la machine très vite et
et c'est ce qu'onevit de nouveau
aujourd'hui alors ça c'est pour le
contexte historique merci beaucoup
pieras
Alexandra je pose la question générale
de ce débat est-ce que pour vous l'ONU
aujourd'hui sert encore à quelque
chose oui
forcément je voulais aussi dire que la
différ entre l'ONU et l'asdn c'est que
dans l'ONU il y a les grandes puissances
qui n'étaient pas
là dans laasdn et c'est ce qui fait
toute la la différence et l'objectif des
Nations Unies assigné par la
Charte aux organes des Nations Unies et
notamment au Conseil de sécurité c'est
de donner la responsabilité de ce
maintien de la paix et la sécurité
internationale aux grandes puissances
parce qu'on considérait à l'époque que
euh seul ces grandes puissances avaient
les moyens diplomatiques politiques
militaires de euh de de de maintenir
cette paix qu'on considérait pouvoir
être euh euh mise à mal par des petits
états des moyens États mais quand une
grande puissance devient l'agresseur la
Russie en Ukraine tout tout le château
de carte s'effondre oui ça tout à fait
bien s dire le contraire bien sûr mais
pendant euh mais depuis
1945 quand même les Nations Unies h ont
évité une trè guerre
mondiale on y reviendra en détail je
vous reposerai la question tiens ça
m'intéresse ça l'ONU c'est aussi vous
avez parlé des casques bleus la présence
physique de 76000 casques bleus un peu
partout sur la planète on a trouvé ce
chiffre sur le site ONU France on va
voir la carte des contingents les plus
importants ils sont très largement en
afriquein également au Liban je vais pas
citer tous les chiffres plus de 18000 en
centra-afrique 18000 au Soudan au libana
10000 en RDC République démocratique du
Congo 17000 chiffre qui datent de juin
2023 qui ont pu évoluer depuis sou oui
on est d'accord ces casques bleus est-ce
est-ce on a l'impression notamment dans
dans les pays africains qu'ils arrivent
plus forcément à protéger les civiles
est-ce qu'il y a pas là aussi un sorte
de constat d'impuissance sur le rôle des
casques bleus oui mais qui est aussi le
résultat de mandat de plus en plus
complexe j'étais au Mali justement le
mandat de la inusma il était extrêmement
large et compliqué donc il y avait bien
sûr cette dimension de protection des
civils mais il y avait aussi de la lutte
antiterroriste il y avait du
développement à la fois économique il y
avait de la protection de
l'environnement donc on leur demande
trop c'est ça ce que vous nous dites bah
oui peut-être en tout cas que on on a
par par une ambition trop importante et
qui n'est pas suivie de de soutien
politique aussi parce que le résultat
aussi de l'échec des missions de
maintien de la paix c'est aussi euh des
divergences entre les membres du Conseil
de sécurité notamment ouis et euh et
voilà et donc euh c'est à mon avis ce
qui explique aussi l'échec de l'échec
relatif de certaines de ces missions de
maintien pierre hasky si si on continue
de faire un peu d'histoire il y a eu des
périodes relativement récent récentes où
l'ONU a démontré sa capacité d'agir je
pense par exemple les années 90 2000 les
les années 90 ont été euh la la période
peut-être la plus favorable h par
ilitensn après la de Berlin
souvenez-vous quand même de la guerre du
Golf numéro 1 donc en 1991 lorsque
l'Irak avait avalé le le
kwiit la première guerre du Golf a reçu
l'aval de toutes les puissances du
Conseil de sécurité donc le RSS qui
existait encore et et les États-Unis et
c'était la guerre consensuelle par
excellence c'est-à-dire on va empêch ch
un pays d'avaler son voisin par la force
avec la le la communauté internationale
derrière c'était le le cadre idéal le
contre-exemple c'est évidemment ce qui
s'est passé en 2003 toujours en Irak
lorsque les Américains envahissent
l'Irak sans l'aval des Nations Unies
puisque la France avait menacé de mettre
son véau à une intervention et donc les
Américains s'en sont passés ont court
circuité les Nations Unies et sont
retournés en Irak donc on a euh ce ce
moment un peu un peu prometteur de des
années 90
l'émission en exyugoslavie à Sarajevo
qui ont un bilan extrêmement mitigé et
pas forcément et ça s'arrête en fait en
2011 avec l'intervention en liby qui a
le soutien de de la Russie c'est
Medvedev qui est Président c'est pas
Poutine à ce moment-là la Russie
soutient l'intervention pour empêcher un
massacre à Bazi et Poutine euh est
furieux parce que il estime que les
Occidentaux sont allés au-delà du mandat
avec la mort de Kaddafi et ont procédé à
un changement de régime et c'est la fin
de la décennie de collaboration ouais
Alexandra vous disiez l'ONU a permis
d'éviter la trè guerre mondiale quand
Ben jusqu'à présent c'estàd que longs
d'une certaine façon oui c'est-à-dire
que le le
fait finalement le le vetto est une
sorte de de soupable de sécurité
c'est-à-dire qu'ilempêche euh les
grandes puissances de se faire la guerre
parce que et il il il conduit les États
à négocier tent et plus regardez ce qui
s'est passé dans la sur la dernière
résolution de de
décembre de l'année dernière sur
Gaza les états voulaient absolument les
les les Américains que les Américains
votent bon benah on a négocié jusqu'au
bout euh pour que les les les Américains
puissent
s'abstenir alors c'est pas toujours
idéal puisque on dit bah du coup c'est
un peu le le plus petit dénominateur
commun mais en l'occurrence ça a permis
à l'aide humanitaire de de rentrer mais
de nommer un envoyé pour un
coordonnateur pour pour cette aide
humanitaire vous pensez qu'il faut
garder le droit de vetto tel quel
aujourd'hui au Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU ça fait beaucoup débateçon de
toute façon on n pas le choix puis par
que si on veut abolir le droit de vetto
il faut changer le texte de la Charte et
ça c'est le tabou absolu pour l'ensemble
des États membres des Nations Unies vous
dites c'est irréformable à ce niveaulors
c'est un bon c'est un bonme je l'avis
prévu plus tard mais c'est pas grave on
va le faire maintenant on va regarder
parce que on s'est intéressé au nombre
de droit de véau on va rappeler comment
conseil fonctionne effectivement ce ce
Conseil de sécurité cinq membres
permanent Russie États-Unis Royaume-Uni
Chine et France et vous avez le nombre
de de de droit de vé ça ça a dû évoluer
là aussi les les chiffres d' un tout
petit peu c'est c'est notamment pour la
Russie il en a eu un peu plus depuis 143
86 États-Unis 30 Royaume-Uni Chine et
France 18 je voudrais vous entendre tous
les trois vous avez commencé à en parler
peut-être Johan soufi je crois que la
France et le RoyaumeUni avait proposé
une réforme du droit de vetto ça a été
retoqué pourquoi oui moi je suis pas
d'accord sur le fait de dire que le
droit de veto protégerait en quelque
sorte la paix j'ai plutôt l'impression
que le droit de vet et à la fois un
anachronisme quelque chose d'obsolète
d'un monde qui aujourd'hui n'existe plus
à l'époque il y avait encore les
colonies et aussi un paradoxe le
paradoxe c'est que l'ONU promeut une
bonne gouvernance une démocratie des
valeurs universel et à un instrument qui
est profondément autoritaire qui est que
un état contre le reste de la communauté
internationaleo peut bloquer et c'est
exactement ce qu'on voit à Gaza
aujourd'hui donc je suis pas d'accord
sur ce c'était quoi la la proposition de
réforme pierreask peut-être en quelques
mot alors il il y avait une proposition
de réforme de de limiter le champ
d'application du du droit de vetto
c'est-à-dire qui ne soit pas applicable
lorsqu'il y avait par exemple un risque
de génocide ou une catastrophe
absolument
considérable et on on pouvait pas
permettre à un des détenteurs du droit
de veto de bloquer une action de la
communauté internationale mais même ça
ça a été refusé et comme vous l'avez dit
c'est c'est très compliqué de réformer
quoi que ce soit dans la Charte de l'ONU
parce qu'il faut l'unanimité des CIN
membres et que il y aura toujours l'un
des trois qui qui refusera c'est-à-dire
Chine Russie ou États-Unis en
l'occurrence les trois étaient d'accord
pour refuser si je me souviens
bienit mais c'est logique parce que ce
sont les trois grandes puissances qui
veulent se garder une liberté d'action
il faut quand même savoir sur les
chiffres que vous avez donné c'est que
sur les 25 dernières années je me trompe
peut-être mais je crois que au
Royaume-Uni et la France donc les deux
Européens n'ont pas utilisé leur veto
euh et que et que donc le le le veto est
un anachronisme qui reste euh le le le
le l'apanage des des trois euh super
puissances ou grande puissan euh l'autre
anachronisme c'est évidemment que vous
l'avez dit ça exclut les puissances qui
n'étaient pas indépendantes au moment de
la naissance de l'ONU et et qui sont
aujourd'hui des puissances majeures euh
je pense à l'Inde au Brésil ou euh ou à
l'Afrique du Sud si on peut si on veut
avoir une ouis
réis la représentativité ou trois pays
qui font partie des des bricks
évidemment qui son ce qui n'est pas
hasard qui sont qui est en train
organisation qui est en train de monter
en puissance Alexandra Novoselov c'est
c'est vous êtes d'accord quand même pour
dire que cette ce Conseil de sécurité il
est d'une certaine façon je reprends
l'argument
obsolète c'est la photographie d'un
autre temps c'est c'est comment ça peut
être accepté par justement ces autres
pays du monde très peuplés de plus en
plus puissant bon d'abord le Conseil de
sécurité a été créé pour être un organe
restreint qui puisse prendre des
décisions rapidement euh et et il a ces
cinq puissances parce que ce sont elles
qui ont la volonté et les capacités
diplomatiques politiques militaire
économique d'éventuellement intervenir
euh parce que pour maintenir la paix et
la sécurité internationale il faut bien
intervenir à un moment donné hein avec
soit des pressions diplomatiques et
politiques soit une intervention
militaires soit des sanctions
économiques donc il faut intervenir faut
avoir le poids politique de pour se
faire euh donc donc c'est donc c'est ça
l'objectif du conseil quand il est uni
si s'il était pardon vous interrompre
s'il s'il était élargi il fonctionnerait
moins bien d'après ah bah oui bien sûr
HM on l'a vu à l'Union européenne quand
euh l'Union européenne est passée à 27
céit c'était beaucoup plus compliqué de
prendre des décisions donc et et encore
une fois à l'Union européenne on est des
dans les ce qu'on appelle les likeemed
c'est-à-dire des des des pays qui ont
grosso modo les mêmes intérêts au
Conseil de sécurité on est dans c'est
c'est c'est le monde entier et donc on a
des gens là des états hein c'est c'est
une organisation d'État il faut il faut
le rappeler avec des intérêts et c'est
des états des intérêts extrêmement
divergents votre avis là-dessus Yan
soufi est-ce que c'est pas la la
principale réforme qu'il faudrait mener
bien sûr parce que je suis pas d'accord
le à nouveau à mon avis il y a deux
choses la première chose c'est que
l'organisation le l'organe le plus
universel le plus démocratique c'est
l'assemblée générale même si il y a
effectivement un problème en terme après
de représentativité de la population
puisque c'est une voie par état mais
donc ça c'est pas le Conseil de sécurité
et après ce raisonnement de dire le
Conseil de sécurité c'est les cinq États
qui ont la puissance c'est un peu un
raisonnement circulaire parce que ils
ont effectivement une puissance à la
fois politique et militaire aussi parce
qu'ils sont membres du Conseil de
sécurité mais si on donnait à l'Inde par
exemple qui deviendra une enfin qui déjà
une puissance régionale ou à d'autres
pays et bien il serait aussi en capacité
d'agir sur des terrains d'opération
et mais pas avec la volonté ils n'ont
pas la volonté oui moi je pense que en
fait le monde que vous décrivez n'existe
plus c'est-à-dire que euh à partir du
moment où les États-Unis attaquent
l'Irak sans l'accord du Conseil de
sécurité et que la Russie euh envahit
son voisin l'Ukraine euh cette cette
logique là ne fonctionne plus euh et
donc euh je pense qu' on est dans une
phase de recomposition totale des des
équilibres géopolitiques et que l'ONU ne
sera pas la même euh elle ne pourra pas
être la même parce que elle n'est plus
adaptée à notre monde ce monde est en
train de craquer donc il faudra changer
d'une manière ou d'une autre que ce on
est peut-être au même état que que
lorsqu'on a remplacé la SDN par l'ONU je
pense en terme de de de craquement du
système oua on va continuer en débattre
et peut-être imaginer ce que pourrait
être une nouvelle instance
internationale Tam je vous donne la
parole parce que d'une certaine façon
c'est voilà ça s'appelle un éditorial et
vous voulez nous dire pourquoi d'après
vous l'ONU reste malgré les critiques
indispensables voilà c'est un parti prix
allons-y ça va rebour effectivement des
refrains ambiants l'ONU paralysé par son
conseil de sécurité l'ONU impuissante à
Gaza en Ukraine pour les Ouigours en
Haïti partout o se présente finalement
une situation de crise on a l'impression
aujourd'hui d'un disque rayé chaque fois
qu'un conflit armé se présente on a
l'impression que l'ONU reste là les bras
ballant mais si ce machin pour reprendre
les mots du général de Gaul et les
vôtres tout à l'heure Thomas existe
depuis près de 80 ans et réunit
aujourd'hui 193 pays sur cinq continents
est seulement pour faire des moulinets
l'ONU représente quasiment tous les pays
du monde chacun dispose unee voix dans
son assemblée générale c'est un lieu
d'échange il y a pas d'autre instance
qui puisse rassembler autant de
ministres des affaires étrangères de la
planète et enfin l'ONU a été fondé sur
des valeurs résolument progressistes la
démocratie les droits de l'homme la paix
le progrès social et puis on lui doit la
Déclaration universelle des droits de
l'Homme de 1948 on lui droit la
Convention sur les droits de l'enfant
1989 la déclaration sur les droits des
peuples autochtone 2007 ce n'est donc
pas rien ok sont des textes fondamentaux
pour l'instant ils ont plutôt une portée
symbolique quand même car entre les
textes et leur ratification entre les
paroles les actes il y a parfois un
faussé il faut déjà que les ambitions
internationales deviennent des
préoccupations nationales mais est-ce la
faute de l'ONU si par exemple les
États-Unis n'ont pas ratifié la
Convention de l'enfant est-ce que ce
n'est pas plutôt la responsabilité des
États on prend les États-Unis il juge la
Convention de l'ONU antiamille le
résultat c'est que de nombreux États
américains autorisent les châtiments
corporels les mariages entre les enfants
ou encore le travail des enfants donc
ratifier la Convention des droits de
l'enfant de l'ONU ça serait peut-être
pas mal dans ces conditions ensuite oui
l'ONU elle est impuissante à pacifier
les conflits mais du coup ces agences
n'en paraissent que plus indispensables
pour protéger 1177 millions de personnes
qui fuit la guerre pour apporter de
l'aide humanitaire à 160 millions de
personnes pour couvrir les besoins en
vaccin de 45 % des enfants dans le monde
et j'en passe et puis enfin dans notre
monde globalisé on se dit aussi qu'il
faut une organisation démocratique
mondiale qui doit transcender les
limites étatiques sur bien d'autres
enjeux les épidémies la pollution
l'évasion fiscale par exemple alors que
les Pandora papers ont révélé que 13 %
de la richesse mondiale était dissimulé
à l'abri de l'impôt dans les paradis
fiscaux bien d'accord avec vous il faut
une organisation internationale la
question c'est est-ce que c'est celle-là
ou est-ce que c'est une nouvelle est-ce
qu'il faudrait est-ce qu'il faut encore
confier des missions supplémentaires à
l'ONU alors qu'elle peine peut-être à
remplir les siennes alors d'accord on va
pas mettre la charue avant les bœfs mais
est-ce que vous allez mettre votre bonne
conscience à la poubelle parce que vous
ne l'écoutez jamais
cert Antonio Gutiérrez apparaît de plus
en plus comme une P apocalyptique qui
prêche dans le désert mais pourquoi
parce que l'ONU doit être réformée dans
ses mécanismes de décision on a parlé du
Conseil de sécurité parce qu'elle doit
avoir des pouvoir de sanction il faut
qu'il soit fait pression sur les états
pour ratifier ces conventions bref il
faut la volonté politique de lui donner
du pouvoir et des responsabilités l'un
nimplique un l'autre comme l'ont
expliqué Churchill Roosevelt et
Spiderman pour que l'ONU ne soit pas un
forum sans aucun poids où l'on se
contentit de dire qu'échanger bah c'est
mieux que rien un simple reflet
imparfait d'un monde qui est tout autant
voire de plus en plus merci imaginons
une nouvelle organisation internationale
pierreask pas facile non alors déjà je
retiens une chose c'est que il faut
distinguer les organisations
spécialisées de l'ONU comme la FAO qui
l'agriculture le HCR des réfugiés et
cetera qui font un travail
extraordinaire pour certaines pas toutes
don le fonctionnement peut être
améliorer mais en tout cas qui sont
indispensables et et et le monde serait
bien moins bien moins humain
sans ne jetons pas tout le bébé aveceau
duain la partie dont on a parlé au début
c'est le fonctionnement politique
maintien de la paix qui est défaillant
on le voit bien par l'absence de
paix moi je pense que que si si demain
il doit y avoir une nouvelle instance
elle doit être d'abord plus
représentative c'est-à-dire tenir compte
du fait que l'ONU a été créé avant les
les décolonisation et que le le monde
aujourd'hui est évidemment extrêmement
différent et que si on veut une relative
représentativité y compris dans les
instances de décision elle doit tenir
compte de de cette évolution ça c'est la
le le premier point et et souvenez-vous
quand même parce que c'est avant même de
parler de la décolonisation on parlait
de cet anachronisme c'était que c'était
les vainqueurs de la guerre donc il n'y
avait ni l'Allemagne ni le Japon qui
était qui sont devenus des puissances
majeures économique régionales et cetera
et qui ne n'ont pas voix au chapitre
parce que les réformes étaient
impossibles donc cette réforme là elle
doit être plus représentative et la
deuxième c'est mais ça c'est un rêve et
c'est une utopie je pense que l'ONU doit
être plus autonome c'est-à-dire
aujourd'hui le ça a été dit l'ONU c'est
la la somme des États-membres donc on ne
peut rien faire si les États-membres ne
ne sont pas d'accord entre eux ce qui
est le cas aujourd'hui l'ONU devrait
avoir dans un monde idéal mais ça c'est
la supr naationalité la capacité de
décider d'envoyer des casques
bleus à la frontière entre l'Ukraine et
la Russie même si la Russie ne veut pas
oui bon c'est c'est impossible c'est
inimaginable mais est-ce que c'est pas
ça euh vers vers voilà le monde dans
lequel on pourrait tendre un jour avec
une sorte de délégation de souveraineté
euh qui permettrait de garder la paix
dans le monde autrement on est à la
mercie de des des super puissants qui
continueront à être les prédateurs de la
planète parce que si vous faites le
bilan depuis 80 ans euh une bonne partie
des conflits de cette planète ont été
créés par les les les plus grandes
puissances et je suis pas d'accord avec
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur le
fait que l'ONU a empêché la trème guerre
mondiale je pense que c'est l'équilibre
de la terreur qui a empêché la trème
guerre mondiale c'est le jour où après
la crise de Cuba les Soviétiques et les
Américains se sont rendus compte queils
pouvaient détruire 50 fois la planète et
et et que personne n'en sortirait vivant
c'est à ce moment-là qu'on a fait un pas
en arrière et qu'on a commencé à se
parler l'ONU est peut-être a peut-être
été un des cadre mais voilà c'est pour
ça que je pense que on on n'est pas dans
une situation très favorable aujourd
pour imaginer un are alors vous parliez
de évidemment de de de l'Ukraine
l'agression russe février 2022 je vous
propose une réaction on est plusieurs
mois après 20 septembre 2023 session
exceptionnelle du conseil de de sécurité
de l'ONU et Catherine ConA qui à
l'époque est ministre des Affaires
étrangères parle d'une agression contre
les Nations Unies écoutez là oui cette
guerre est une guerre contre l'Ukraine
contre les Ukrainiennes et les
Ukrainiens mais c'est aussi une guerre
contre contre les règles de la vie
internationale car c'est une guerre
contre les principes les plus
fondamentaux de notre charte commune en
premier lieu ce du respect de la
souveraineté et de l'intégrité
territoriale des États c'est une guerre
contre l'idée même des Nations
Unies Alexandra Novoselov est-ce que ce
conflit n'oblige pas d'une certaine
façon à à réfléchir ou à essayer
d'imposer voilà une nouvelle instance
internationale alors c'est peut-être le
pire moment hein quand quand on quand on
est dans un dans un tel contexte
guerrier a priori oui je veux dire on on
peut réfléchir à tout mais mais qui met
sur
pied cette qui mettrait ce sur pied oui
mais il faut un accord pour ça dans un
monde qui est totalement divisé euh vous
trou la donc on garde l'enu faute de
mieux quoi c'est ce que vous nous dites
bah euh bon d'abord comme vous le
rappeliez euh l'ONU remplit un certain
nombre de de de tâches euh et ensuite
moi je trouve que euh au lieu de
critiquer euh l'ONU entre guillemets
hein c'est chacun de nous l'ONU il faut
aussi euh il faudrait critiquer le
manque d'application des résolutions du
Conseil de sécurité comme de l'assemblée
générale par les mêmes États qui les ont
votés ou euh et c'est ça le cœur du
sujet c'est pas une autre organisation
c'est déjà si on commençait à appliquer
les
résolutions du Conseil on serait déjà
dans un monde un peu meilleur et toute
organisation a des limites et les
limites des Nations Unies et en
particulier de la partie paix et
sécurité c'est l'accord entre les grands
États
qu'aujourd'hui ce soit les cinq actuels
ou que demain on est d'autres il y aura
toujours des tensions il y aura toujours
des divisions
euh Johan soufi est-ce qu'il y a quand
même une une pression notamment des des
bricks de ces de ces états donc Brésil
Russie Inde Chine Afrique du Sud qui ont
été rejoint par plusieurs états depuis
quelques quelques mois est-ce qu'il y a
une pression pour réformer l'ONU ou
est-ce que finalement ça n'existe pas
vraiment ça j'ai l'impression comme vous
l'avez dit qu'il y a plutôt un accord
entre puissanceces pour une fois la
Chine les États-Unis et la Russie sont
sur la même longueur d'onde
effectivement il y a une énorme pression
moi j'ai l'impression à la
fois des puissances émergent mais aussi
des États africains je veux dire on a on
a un tiers des pays membres de l'ONU qui
sont Africains qu' absolument aucune
voix au chapitre mais j'ai l'impression
même qu'au-delà de ça on a aussi une
pression de la société civile y compris
dans les pays qui qui ont un un un
véteau comme la France l'Angleterre ou
les États-Unis pour justement réformer
euh
l'ordre mondial et aller vers quelque
chose de plus juste et de plus universel
moi en tout cas c'est c'est mon
sentiment mais qui se reflète pas après
dans dans les décisions politiques des
États alors il y a un chapitre qu'il
faut ouvrir dans ce débat sur le le rôle
la personnalité du Secrétaire général
des Nations unies Antonio goutérez
propose à audre vetas de nous rejoindre
de nouveau sur ce plateau re bonsoir
audre Antonio gutirez qui est le
président de l'ONU depuis 2017 oui pour
vous donner aperçu de sa personnalité
voici une phrase qu'il a prononcé avant
son élection en tant que secrétaire
général de l'ONU je ne serai ni
secrétaire ni général comprendre je ne
seraai pas la chambre d'enregistrement
du Conseil de sécurité pas non plus un
leader autoritaire vous avez sa marque
de fabrique le Portugais de 74 ans
ancien Premier ministre et tranchant
adepte de la phrase choc qui met souvent
au profit de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique comme l'an
dernier en visitant les dégâts après de
terribles inondations au Pakistan
écoutez
j'ai vu de nombreux désastres
humanitaires dans le monde mais je n'ai
jamais vu de carnage climatique de cette
ampleur les pays riches ont la
responsabilité morale d'aider les pays
en développement comme le Pakistan à se
remettre de telles catastrophe et à
s'adapter parce que malheureusement
elles se répèteront à
l'avenir vous l'avez entendu l'ancien
haut commissaire pour les réfugiés semé
du côté des pays en voie de
développement nésite pas non plus à
pointer du Doig les pays en grande
partie responsable il faut le dire du
dérèglement climatique résultat il est
le chouchou de la génération climat et
des communautés scientifiques et ça
c'est peut-être à chercher du côté de
son passé justement parce que son
engagement commence en 1967 il a alors
18 ans et à cette époque Lisbonne est
frappé par des inondations meurtrières
le pays qui est encore sous la dictature
de Salazar ne parvient pas à faire face
à cette crise les associations
étudiantes prennent le relais sur le
terrain et notamment les jeunes
catholiques universitaires dont gouter
fait partie c'est le début d'une longue
carrière nationale et internationale il
a donc été élu secrétaire général de
l'ONU en 2017 puis renouvelé à
l'unanimité à son poste en 2022 ce qui
me permet de vous dire rapidement que
les mandats de secrétaire général durent
5 ans et qu'il n'y a pas de limite au
renouvellement même s'ils en ont tous
fait deux ou un notons que gouterz est
un ancien ingénieur et c'est peut-être
pour cela qu'il est si sensible au
rapport des scientifiques et notamment
du JEC alors si on rentre dans le
registre des critiques certains estiment
que cette surenchère climatique c'est
leur terme lui permet de masquer
d'autres questions oui notamment le fait
que l'ONU est de plus en plus décrié ça
vous en avez longuement parlé et qu'elle
a plusieurs fois échoué à résoudre des
crises notamment en 2019 gouteres
c'était personnalement investi pour
résoudre la crise libyenne ça s'est
conclu par un échec il a aussi été
critiqué pour n'avoir pas réagi assez
vite avant l'invasion massive de la
Russie en Ukraine et puis plus récemment
ce sont ses propos hand lemain des
attaques massives du Hamas en Israël le
7 octobre qui ont fait polémique je vous
propose
d'écouter les violences les plus
récentes ne surviennent pas dans
n'importe quel contexte la réalité est
qu'elle découle d'un conflit de longue
date avec une occupation qui dure depuis
56 ans et dont aucune issue politique
n'est en vue alors il faut tout de même
souligner qu'il a vivement condamné les
attaques du Hamas mais cette
justification entre guillemets a créé un
tolé du côté des autorités israéliennes
qui ont même demandé sa
les critiques souligneront que son
surnom et alors pardon pour mon
portugais son surnom c'est la picareta
fente comprendre la pioche qui parle
peut-être qu'il parle un peu trop Thomas
merci beaucoup Audrey pour pour toutes
ces informations pierre on va on va se
concentrer sur le le rôle de d'Antonio
guterz que pèent ces mots aujourd'hui
j'ai l'imession pas grand-chose mais je
suis peut-être un peu trop critique non
je je crains que vous soyez dans le vrai
c'est-à-dire
que c'est une parole qui compte parce
que il a le poids moral et il représente
une institution dans laquelle tous les
pays de la planète sont quasiment tous
représentés c'est la bonne conscience
dont parlait Tam tout à l'heure d'une
certaine façon mais mais la bonne
conscience n'a pas d'impact réel et on
le voit sur les les grands conflits de
l'heure que ce soit l'Ukraine ou ou Gaza
le secrétaire général des Nations unies
n'a strictement aucun impact et et c'est
là que que que
c'est c'est la faillite de de de ceci
système aujourd'hui parce que quand même
ce qu'il a dit sur sur le 7 octobre
c'est du bon sens parce qu'il est quand
même le secrétaire général d'une
organisation qui a voté un nombre
incalculable de résolutions qui sont
restés lettrre mortes sur le le les
territoires occupés palestiniens et donc
s'il s'était tu je pense qu'il aurait
pas été dans dans son rôle il a parlé
mais ça n'a strictement aucun impact
concret sur le déroulement du conflit
donc c'est c'est quelqu'un je pense de
très digne et et qui est respectable et
qui a une parole sensée je moi je me
souviens pas de dérapage d'Antonio
gouterz contrairement à d'autres
secrétaires généraux il y a pas toujours
eu des des des très bons choix
mais c'est le reflet de tout ce qu'on a
dit depuis le début ouis on va parler de
son rôle justement dans dans dans le
conflit entre Israël et leohamas mais
d'abord peut-être un rappel historique
Alexandra Novoselov le secrétaire
général des Nations unies il peut
devenir une cible le Suédois dag
amarskiol là aussi mon mon suédois est
mauvais forcément mort dans un accident
d'avion en septembre
1961 est-ce qu'on lui a fait payer son
indépendance alors on sait pas si c'est
un accident ou si c'était voilà ça reste
flou donc Bonou euh mais c'est sûr que
le secrétaire général des Nations unies
il doit être impartial mais mais il a
des marges de manœuvre extrêmement
compliqué puisque à chaque fois qu'il
prend la parole il peut euh euh un état
et ça a été le cas quand le Antonio
gterz a a a parlé de de de cette du fait
que le conflit ne date pas d'hier euh il
y a tout de suite le le ministre des
Affaires étrangères israélien qui lui
est tombé dessus et donc voilà la la les
marges manœuvre sont extrêmement euh euh
limité et puis il n'a pas de bras armé
le secrétaire général il n'a pas de
division et donc quand il veut faire
quelque chose il doit demander aux États
hein ceux qui font dans cette
organisation ce sont les états c'est eux
qui fournissent des casques bleus c'est
eux qui fournissent de l'aide
humanitaire et cetera et
cetera donc c'est eux
qui qui payent le budget des Nations
unies sur contribution obligatoire en
partie ou sur contribution volontaire et
ça aussi un un un impact sur ce qu'il
sur ce que l'ONU fait ou sur ce que le
secrétaire général va dire ou pas alors
sur le confit Israël ramas l'ONU est au
cœur de l'actualité évidemment mais
notamment via sa cour internationale de
justice on est dans ces instances dont
on parlait tout à l'heure 11 janvier
donc il y a une semaine premier jour de
l'audience de cette international de
justice elle est saisi un recours contre
Israël plainte pour génocide déposé par
l'Afrique du Sud on écoute le ministre
de la Justice
sudafricain le fait que l'État d'Israël
est tenu de rendre des comptes devant la
communauté internationale fera une
énorme différence les soldats savent les
autorités israéliennes savent que si
elle continue elle pourrait même un jour
être convoquée individuellement devant
la CPI et avoir à répondre de leurs
actes le message est donc clair ils
doivent cesser il doivent renoncer aux
actes de
génocide Johan souhie que sur quoi peut
déboucher une telle procédure un tel
recours d'abord une décision légale et
et la décision de la Cour notamment de
savoir s'il existe des raisons
plausibles qu'il y ait un risque de
génocide ça ça aura une valeur juridique
donc ce sera plus un débat d'opinion et
après pas seulement une valeur
symbolique une valeur juridique une
valeur juridique et mais après on on
revient à chaque fois au même problème
c'est-à-dire que la la décision aura une
valeur contraignante après il revient
aux États de la mettre en œuvre et donc
il y aura pas de sanction et donc en
tout cas euh tant que les États-Unis
bloqueront euh par exemple une mise en
œuvre par un véteau il y aura pas de
sanction effective mais euh ensuite
c'est aussi la conformité et la
cohérence des États-Unis de leurs
valeurs avec avec leurs actes et donc à
partir du moment moi où j'ai
l'impression où si les Américains par
exemple mettaient un véau et bien c'est
leur discours aussi sur d'autres
conflits sur l'Ukraine notamment mais
sur d'autres conflits qui seraiit du
coup moins crédiible et donc c'est une
fondation même de notre Ordre Mondial
qui serait à mon avis c'est intéressant
ce que vous dites parce que c'est à la
fois du juridique et c'est très
politique c'estàdire que c'est cette
procédure elle existe aussi pour placer
les États-Unis devant leur contradiction
c'est c'est c'est c'est ça ce que je
comprends dans votre démonstration moi
je pense que cette cette procédure par
l'Afrique du Sud elle a une double
symbolique elle est d'abord l'absence
des États occidentaux qui sont
d'habitude très présent sur ces
questions et qui l'ont été admirablement
sur l'Ukraine et elle est aussi par son
histoire l'Afrique du Sud la
colonisation l'apartthide mais aussi
mais aussi comme un État du sud qui
aujourd'hui se revendique comme une
démocratie qui a réussi sa transition
d'être présent sur ces questions pour
pour avoir un peu une dimension
universelle justement pierasky le fait
que ce soit l'Afrique du Sud qui dépose
ce recours qu'est-ce que ça ça dit c'est
c'est une démonstration quoi d'une
nouvelle époque on tion Unies d'une
certaine façon oui je pense que c'est
c'est très significatif parce que on le
voit depuis le le début de la guerre
d'Ukraine d'ailleurs le le tout le monde
a été surpris par l'attitude d'une
partie des pays du Sud qui n'ont pas
adhéré au discours occidental qui de
dire mais il y a une violation du droit
international pourquoi vous ne condamnez
pas voilà il beaucoup beaucoup
d'abstention ou de non participation au
vote et et et la réponse de ces pays ça
été de dire oui mais vous avez aussi
violé le le droit international les
doubles standard c'est quelque chose
qu'on a beaucoup entendu au cours des
deux dernières années et là tout d'un
coup l'Afrique du Sud est le pays qui
euh euh avec son passé d'aparthide et de
victoire sur l'aparide a incarner cette
prise de position cette prise de pouvoir
j'ai l'impression symbolique euh de de
l'espace publque qui était monopolisé
par les Occidentaux et c'est tout
l'enjeu de de cette recomposition dont
on parle c'est-à-dire que euh c'est la
fin du monopole occidental de de la
parole et de la puissance l'arrogance
occidentaleut-êre de l'arrogance très
certainement et et et pour déboucher sur
quoi c'est pas très évident parce que
une partie de de de de ces puissances
qui contestent l'ordre occidental ne le
font pas au nom de valeurs démocratiqu
elles le font avec des systèmes
autoritaires qui euh sont aux antipodes
donc on a quelque chose d'extrêmement
ambigu et et et pas clair en tout cas
sur le sur sur quoi ça va déboucher et
c'est toute cette recomposition du monde
dans laquelle on est en ce moment et
c'est pour ça que que les conflit comme
aussi bien l'Ukraine que Gaza on ont
pris cette cette dimension non seulement
militaire et et et et et régional mais
symbolique et politique au niveau de de
de la communauté internationale oui avec
la la question du du risque de
d'escalade de ce conflit au au au Proche
Orient on va s'appuyer sur un exemple
qui est vraiment encore dans l'actualité
aujourd'hui puis les attaques des
rebelles outil contre des des navires
commerciaux dans la la mer Rouge
conséquence évidemment sur le canal de
sues qui est en train de s' fixer sur
l'économie égyptienne par effet domino
et sur le commerce mondial qui passe
évidemment 12 % du commerce mondial qui
passe par ce canal de de de Sue sauf que
Alexandre nooselov c'est c'est pas l'ONU
qui est qui qui a la manœuvre en
l'occurrence c'est c'est les Américains
et et les Britanniques qui qui alors
voilà on peut on peut le regret ou dire
heureusement qu'ils sont là qui sont en
train de d'essayer d'empêcher les les
rebelles outils armés par l'Iran de de
de de tirer ses missiles oui enfin le le
le Conseil de sécurité a adopté une
résolution le 10 janvier hein je crois
donc voilà c'est plus une une résolution
pour
condamner ces ces
attaques mais oui il y a pas de peut pas
tel qu'elle fonctionne aujourd'hui l'ONU
pard n interrompr l'ONU ne peut pas
aller plus loin dans dans ce cas
particulier mais il il y a pas de
d'unité au sein du conseil pour aller
pour faire pour faire quoi
pour bah mettre mettre en œuvre une une
force internationale pour ramener le
calme en mer Rouge et donc permettre
pardon d'être très prosaïque au commerce
mondial de fonctioner si les États ne
veulent pas intervenir pour donner des
des soldats pour cette force
internationale elle n'existe pas enfin
je veux dire donc voilà c'est c'est
c'est là le c'est là l'enjeu s'il n'y a
pas de de volonté et de d'une grande
coalition pour euh pour faire plus que
ce qui est fait actuellement par
simplement les les États-Unis et les
Britanniques euh voilà on s'arrête là
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à à ce sens public ce débat
était passionnant je vais rappeler le
titre les titres de vos livres pieraskii
donc c'est apparaître la semaine
prochaine le 24 le 24 voilà soyons
précis une terre doublement promise
israël-pestine un siècle de conflit
c'est c'est aux éditions Stock et
Alexandra Novoselov le Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies àire à
paraarître enfin paru pardon aux
éditions CNRS merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat encore une fois
merci Tam à très bientôt sur sur ce
plateau merci à vous de votre fidélité à
à Sens public je vous dis à lundi pour
un nouveau numéro de cette émission et
puis noter que demain on va continuer de
parler de géopolitique dans la matinale
de Public Sénat puisque l'invité Dorian
Monsin sera le géopolitologue Nicolas
Tenzer merci encore à très bientôt belle
soirée et bon weekend bon vendredi
d'abord